welcome everyone to seafarer's series of
ritual
talks and today's conversation with
steven reichert
these online talks are intended to
showcase how research
conducted by seafarers fellows can help
inform decision making
as governments develop policies to
reopen shuttered societies
and economies in the wake of covid19
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
canadian-based global research
organization
that convenes extraordinary minds from
around the world to address some of the
most important questions facing science
and humanity
like many other organizations cfar has
pivoted quickly to take action on covet
19
launching new projects and initiatives
some of which were highlighting through
this series my name is kate getty
i'm a senior director of research at
seafar and it's my pleasure to introduce
you to
professor steven reichert today steve
is a professor of psychology at the
university of saint andrews
and a leading authority on social
social psychology his work focuses on
questions of social identity
collective behavior crowd behavior and
leadership
and he is a fellow in seafarer's new
boundaries membership and belonging
research program
in recent months steve has served on
behavioral science advisory groups
to both the scottish and uk governments
concerning their responses to the kovit
19 pandemic
and despite how busy that must have kept
him he
has amazingly managed to co-author a
book that was published in late may
titled together apart
the psychology of covid19 given the
intense interest in this topic then and
now
it was published at that time online as
an uncorrected proof
the premise of the book is that unless
or until
a vaccine for the coronavirus is
developed our means of controlling the
spread of infection
depend on behavioral changes and hence
upon human psychology
so in today's webinar steve will share
with us insights from this book
that uses social identity theorizing to
analyze the psychology of the coded 19
pandemic
such as what encourages us to come
together and support one another as a
community to help us through the crisis
before we dive in i'll quickly set the
parameters
for today's session which will last 30
minutes
i'll take my advantage of a position as
host to ask steve the first few
questions before opening it up to
questions from you
the online participants so if you have a
question
please submit it through the q a
function at the bottom of your screen
and lastly i'll mention that the session
is being recorded
and will be available on the cfart
website next week so
welcome steve thanks very much
to start our conversation what is the
field of social psychology
and why is it particularly important to
understand identity and group processes
under the current pandemic okay well let
me start
well i'm not sure whether i'm correcting
you or correcting myself because you
were citing something that i said about
um behavior being at the center of this
until we get a vaccine
actually it's going to be at the center
of this even when we have a vaccine
because a vaccine does not stop the
infection
people getting vaccinated does and
people are going to therefore be willing
to be vaccinated and
the latest polling evidence i saw showed
that um
something like a third of people are
saying they wouldn't take such a vaccine
so there's a huge behavioral question
there
or equally if we discuss masks say
there's a lot of discussion
do masks stop the infection well masks
stop nothing
um wearing a mask might and again we're
talking about behaviors we're talking
about whether people
wear them uh how they wear them how
effectively they wear them
and most obviously with with lockdown
lock down uh as a policy does nothing
unless people agree to be locked down so
right at the core
of every intervention we have including
when we have a vaccine
is dependent upon behavior and human
behavior
now through this pandemic there have
been two
very different approaches to human
behavior and two ways of thinking about
uh the place of the public in the
pandemic response
one is a very traditional view and it's
a rather elitist view
and it's a view that has at its core a
notion that human beings
are essentially psychologically frail we
have a
tenuous grasp on reality we are full of
biases
um we have a tenuous uh
moral compass which is easily thrown
aside
and that fragility is
like exacerbated under conditions a
where we're in the group the group still
further
undermines our rationality and secondly
when there's a crisis
and that's exemplified by the notion of
panic the notion is
that in a crisis people panic a
hollywood disaster film would never be
complete without a scene of people
running away
screaming waving their hands in the air
and clogging up the exits so it's human
psychology and the frailty
of the human subject which turns
a crisis into a tragedy and therefore a
public are a real problem
now when you look more closely at
crises actually that's not what you find
what you find on the whole is actually
people behave in a fairly restrained way
they support each other they don't just
look after themselves
and they are rather resilient when it
happens every
nation thinks that there's something
special about us because we behaved in a
restraint and a supportive way
um so in britain we like to think it's
the blitz spirit that's what does it
we're different from the rest of you
uh if you go to new york they'll tell
you it's the new york spirit you saw it
in 9 11.
actually it happens nearly everywhere
the reason why it happens
is that when we have common fate
when we face a common predicament
what we see is the emergence of a shared
identity
a sense of us and that sense of us that
extension of the self to include
others has a number of consequences
including support for others
coordination with others and therefore
with
others working with others when others
become an asset
to us rather than the problem actually
we become psychologically resilient
we become empowered and we become rather
effective and what we've seen
in this pandemic in many countries
certainly we saw it in the uk i think
you saw it in
canada as well is that when that shared
sense of identity
is understood when it is nurtured by
leadership when it is scaffolded by
policies which bring people together
then
actually the public uh develop a sense
of collective resilience and that sense
of collective resilience is in many ways
the best asset you have in a pandemic
and so just to finish this comment with
for me if i had a top 10 quotes of the
pandemic
i'm sure there will be lists like that
in in sunday magazines and years to come
um my number one would be andrew cuomo
the governor of new york who said
it's not about i it's about we get your
head
around the wii concept and what my work
has tried to do for many years is to try
and understand
the we concept i call it social identity
concept will
uh do and understand how it can be
developed
and harnessed and how the group becomes
the asset rather than the problem in a
pandemic
that's interesting well i'd like to pick
up on the theme that you
mentioned around the role of political
leaders and suggesting that they have a
critical role
in fostering necessary group behaviors
and dealing with a health emergency
what do we know about what's needed in
terms of effective political leadership
in an emergency situation like pandemic
well let me start with the concept of
leadership itself
um and since since since you plugged the
the together apart book also this week
we did we uh
released with with my colleague alex
haslam and michael plathor a book on
leadership
so leadership is something that
interests me and
when you look at traditional notions of
leadership
they are again very hierarchical and
very
elitist and they start from the premise
that what makes a great leader is what
sets them apart from the rest of us you
know the great leader has these amazing
qualities
uh and if only you could understand
what it was if you could isolate this
right stuff and bottle it you would have
solved the problem of leadership
um now the problem with that well it has
many problems first of all it ignores
the fact that
leaders again don't achieve anything on
their own
they literally they achieve it through
followers so uh
leadership which ignores followers is is
an
empty model empirically i mean that
notion of of
uh it is highly gendered great man
leadership has been around for a long
time
um thomas carlisle famously in uh i
think was about 1848 his book on heroes
and hero worship said that
uh history is effectively uh
what great men have done while they were
uh
on earth um thousands of studies trying
to
find empirically what is the quality
that shows leadership
um and they've all failed and they
failed because actually they missed the
point that what makes a great leader
is what actually brings them together
with
the group they seek to lead
what makes them able to represent that
group speak
for that group shape the understanding
of the group
so what the qualities that you need in a
leader
aren't abstract or absolute it's more a
matter of a
fit between our understanding of who we
are and
the leaders definition of who they are
and leaders um we call them
entrepreneurs of identity are very
skilled at telling a narrative of the
group
and a narrative of themselves which
fleshes those two together
and particularly what you need in a
pandemic is you need a sense of
shared identity you need to nurture that
sense of
us-ness you need to bring people
together to
support each other um and actually to
to do the practical things but also to
provide the psychological support
to take us through now if one of the
criteria
for being an effective leader is to
create a unified
group then we see huge differences
between different leaders and different
places um
i think the leaders we've seen who are
effective um
uh so for instance justin ardern perhaps
in new zealand
um luckily enough i don't live in
england i live in scotland so we've seen
it with nicolas sturgeon
actually it's quite interesting when you
when you name the leaders you see they
have something in common
um they tend to be women um but these
are leaders
who have been very effective in
nurturing
uh a sense of us and in representing
that sense
of us and also of course in developing
the policies
which support the collective
self-interest
but again let me make a point here it's
a simple point but actually it's a
rather consequential point
in so much of our social science we
start from the premise
that individuals act in terms of
individual self-interest
and the way to motivate people is to
tell them what is in their individual
self-interest
the problem with that again is it
equates the self with the individual
it ignores the fact that we can define
ourselves in collective
terms and it ignores the fact that
actually in the pandemic
what is important is we don't act for
ourselves as individuals
but we act for the community so
very simply if people acting in terms of
individual self-interest the hell of a
lot of people in this pandemic
would save themselves actually if i do
the cost benefit analysis
i lose more by staying in them by going
out if you're young and you're healthy
actually you don't have much to risk uh
by going out and you lose a hell of a
lot by staying in i have a
16 year old next door who is not very
happy about having to stay in he suffers
far more than i do
so on the basis of individual
self-interest your calculation would say
go out
but of course at a collective level if
you go out
you spread the disease other people get
ill and
die so if you want to contain the
pandemic people need to be
thinking of themselves in terms of that
collective identity
and by and large that's what happened so
for instance i know
the uk data there may well be data in
canada as well but it shows
that actually the main factor which
determined whether people obeyed
lockdown or not
was not their sense of individual risk
it was their sense of communal risk
their sense of community identity so
again
understanding the we concept creating a
sense of
us and representing that sense of us is
absolutely central to leadership
however and actually here um uh i should
i i could try and show how much i know
about canada
but i know nothing about canada but
luckily yeah uh kate you you you
mean yeah i read about bonnie henry
and i loved her quotation about um we're
all in the same
uh storm we're not in the same boat and
the problem is it's all very well
to talk the talk of shared identity
and to talk the talk of an inclusive
sense of us-ness
but of course different people within
the national community are in very
different positions
and are affected very differently
um by the pandemic it's opened up and
shown a spot by tomorrow
all that all our inequalities um and
therefore
part of creating a shared identity is
not only to do it rhetorically but to do
it practically the practical economic
measures of for instance
supporting people so they could afford
to stay at home
giving uh money for those who are
unemployed giving
uh money for those who are self-employed
and and so on and only if in practice
you create the conditions for a shared
experience and a
shared response will you be able to
create that shared identity so as i say
it's a matter
of rhetoric but it's also a matter of
practical policy
uh which means that we're not only in
the same storm but we are
at least to some extent in the same boat
well now that it's been almost four
months at least
in canada since the major covet 19
restrictions were put in place
we're hearing more and more um reference
to things like quarantine fatigue
is there evidence that there are
potential limits to our psychological
ability to put up with restrictions
you see this was a huge controversy in
the uk and before we locked down
we had people talking about behavioral
fatigue uh
and they they actually used it to uh
justify
a delay uh in lockdown in the uk and
that
arguably that could have cost tens of
thousands of lives i mean
um uh depending on how you calculate it
i mean you've lost about eight thousand
lives from what i can see in canada
we've lost about sixty thousand we've
done pretty badly
um and this behave this notion of
behavioral fatigue if
it um uh led to a delay it
it's a big issue okay now
when you look at the notion of fatigue
it is perfectly
true that uh it is difficult to sustain
lockdown over a prolonged period so the
fact that there is fatigue and
compliance
decreases i think is not controversial
what is controversial is what is the
root of that fatigue
is it an essential psychological
fragility and that takes me back to
what i was saying about different
psychological models or is it something
else
so let me give you just one i think very
striking piece of evidence again i
apologize
it's british evidence but i suspect it's
the same in different places
in the uk you found a difference of a
factor of
six between the most affluent and the
least affluent in how often they went
out under under lockdown
okay there's a huge difference in
compliance
but when you looked at motivation when
you looked at the psychological will
to stay in there was no difference
between those groups at all
the difference lay in just basically the
ability to stay at home
and um uh put food on the table
so there are a couple of factors which
are absolutely critical
in determining your ability to go along
with something
one is of course the information you're
given
people might suffer for a cause but if
there's no cause to suffer for people
aren't going to suffer for it so
if the messaging is bad and if the
messaging suggests to you oh well
actually it's all over
there's no danger then people won't
comply so
failures of government messaging we've
seen that in the uk
undermine compliance and the second
thing is practical if people can't
afford
um to stay at home and feed their
families they won't do so
so to my mind the evidence for the
psychological fragility is actually
rather weak people showed
incredible resilience under lockdown i
mean
again in the uk the figures showed that
something like 44
of people were suffering but they still
stayed in i think this has
undermined those notions of fragility
and showed
collective resilience when people work
together the problems as i say have been
those of
messaging and our government has been
very bad at this
and of giving practical support and so
to talk about
fatigue being a psychological problem in
many ways for me
is the government blaming its own
failures on the failure of human
psychology
and i think that's a very dangerous uh
as well as a very unfair thing to do
so as i mentioned at the outset you've
been advising
both the scottish and uk governments on
how to encourage adherence to public
health behaviors
in a previous c4 webinar we had one of
our other fellows tim besley who's part
of our institutions organizations and
growth program who spoke
to the government use of research
evidence for policy making
this seems to be a particularly
political issue
in the uk right now can you tell us
why and how you feel government should
use insights from
academic research both to guide the
pandemic response but also
a post-pandemic recovery so i think the
responsibility
responsibility is always round and
i mean academics have got to be open
about the limits of what we know and the
certainties of our own
evidence and clearly given that
uh covert 19 is new and we're learning
things about it
all the time uh both in epidemiological
terms but also in psychological terms
there are certain things we couldn't
know yet we have some general principles
that we could apply um and there i think
one of the benefits of
of psychological research is that on the
whole we do try and understand
if you like general processes of
behavior so i can
speak for instance to the role of
social identities and social norms in
behavior
and then i can apply that to the
particular types
of identities you've drawn or the
particular types of norms
which is necessary to reconfigure in
order to get behavior so i think
i think we have to be as i say open
about our own limitations
and then from the perspective of
government i think there are two
pitfalls
one being to ignore the science
because the science of course can tell
you what the consequence of particular
actions will be
but the other error and i think it's
equally problematic
is to claim to be led by the science
because if the science can tell you
what particular outcomes are likely to
be what it can't do
is tell you you know how much risk
should you or shouldn't you take
or how do you balance different risks
against each other
because that's a political question or a
value question
if you like and to claim that you are
led by the science can sometimes
hide the political choices which i think
is dangerous and disingenuous
so i think it's very important to get
the balance right and to say that
government should listen to us
and governments should be informed by
the science but governments should not
be led by the science and if they claim
that they are led by the science what
they're trying to do
is to hide their own political choices
and therefore their
political accountability uh behind the
science and then of course what comes
next when things have gone wrong
is to blame the science um for the
political choices that they
made and i see signs of that happening
in the uk
well thank you so much steve for sharing
your insights with us
uh we've got just i think a little under
10 minutes left so i'm going to turn to
some of the questions that have come in
from our audience
um so one question
uh is that so the person has written in
that they find one of the most
challenging parts of covert 19 is that
the effects are delayed
that there's a two-week delay period
between infection and symptoms and it's
hard to know which
types of personal protective measures
are effective
um how is human psychology adapted to
dealing
with this kind of delay between actions
and consequences
yeah well i'm first of all of course the
the asymptomatic transmission issue
we've discovered
is is is is one of the most significant
uh issues of coverage and it's what
makes it actually such a
such a dangerous disease because a lot
of people who don't know that they are
ill
um are going out and and and shedding
the virus
um that's one of the reasons i mean
people thought the major parameters were
if you like how infectious it was
and how many people it killed but the
delay is critical to the epidemiology
it's also critical to issues like why we
should wear masks because a lot of the
time
we can spread the disease without
knowing that we are spreading
uh the disease
i mean there is a lot of research in
psychology
about delayed gratification and uh about
temporality and so on i think also
again actually what it comes down to is
clarity about understanding
and clarity about messaging and it comes
back to actually
an even broader issue if you want to ask
how
are authorities affected and why people
comply
with authorities the literature tends to
suggest that it's not to do with
authorities being able to punish you but
you having a sense of
uh the authorities acting for you and
the authorities
uh being on your side and so work on
procedural justice says
if you want people to go along with
authorities
in many ways treat them as you would a
member of your own group
treat them as a partner and part of
doing that
means being open with people it means
respecting people
it means giving people all the
information that they need
and one of the dangers of this fragility
notion is that if you give people too
much information
they'll panic so we will hide the
complexities from people
because they're not up to it my sense is
that people are fully
able to understand these things as long
as a
government has an adult conversation
with people
respects people and provides a clear
mental model of the nature of the
disease
and so to me this is very much not an
issue of
psychological limitations it's an issue
of the problems of the psychological
government's
uh models which authority has and it's
an issue of
clarity of communication giving us a
clear
mental model and part of that mental
model is an understanding
that we've got to act as if we've got
the virus
even when we haven't and we've got to
take the precautions
as if we could have uh the virus even
when we don't and so i think those forms
of communication
become an absolutely central issue
do you think there'll be a lasting
effect on social interactions even after
the vaccines
developed and deployed see the paradox
of that question i think is i mean so
there's all this debate
about you know how will society change
well the problem is that if you think
that societies are going to inevitably
change
in particular ways you don't fight for
those changes you become
passive which means that they're less
likely to happen
so that's the paradox peridot is the
more you say this is going to happen
the less likely it is to happen for me
i look at it slightly differently i say
what what has this
um uh pandemic shown us and i think it's
shown as two very clear things first of
all
of course it's shown a spotlight on
inequalities
of um certainly of race and ethnicity
um certainly of class certainly of
gender of generation as well
it has shown us how pernicious they are
it has shown us how
murderous they are things that people
knew before but it's become
blindingly obvious and it's also shown
as
that the response when people are angry
at those inequalities is not repression
that simply leads to social disorder
it's to acknowledge
address and to change and so i hope
that that vision both of the
inequalities and of the
inadequacy of a repressive response will
empower us to struggle for a
more equitable society the second thing
it's shown us and
in the sense that's been at the core of
what i've been saying
is it changes our understanding
of the relationship between the
individual and the collective in a quite
profound
way we've always been told the
individual
is relatively rational and the group is
bad for
us it's an idea that came out in the
period of industrialization
basically because of elite fear of the
masses what we've seen in this pandemic
is the power of the group now of course
that power can be used in bad ways and
we see that in pandemics we see
at times we see prejudice we see pogroms
in pandemics but it can be used
positively like dynamite it can be a
destructive power it can be a
constructive power
i think understanding the power of the
collective
and the fact that the collective is not
less rational the individual
is a profound change for our social
sciences
and it raises questions of course about
the relationship between the individual
and the state and perhaps the state
needs to abandon
its paternalistic notion that people are
irrational and needs the state to look
after them
and change it to if you like a notion
that the state has to scaffold
the collective self-organization of
people it's not a cheap option
it's an option for budget cuts because
actually self-organization requires
resources
um it really it requires funds but
certainly i think there are some
profound
visions we've had but they are visions
that give us a notion of what we want to
get they're not going to happen
automatically
and the things are going to have to be
fought for
um i'm looking at time and i'm trying to
decide if i have if i can squeeze in one
more question
um it relates to the fact that uh we
often we probably
well we all likely have multiple
overlapping
kinds of group identity um and one of
which may be
um affiliation with different political
parties
how particularly in canada the us and
the uk political party
affiliation can be quite a strong
element of identity
are there opportunities here to
strengthen solidarity or
to to improve adherence to
public health measures along political
party lines
i mean i hear again i think leadership
is absolutely critical i mean you can
have
polarizing leadership and in fact i mean
to me what's happened in the united
states is quite extraordinary i mean one
has a president
who uh positions himself as the
anti-political
uh president and who is an uh
you know as an insurgent even in office
the office of the president of the
united states
acts as an insurgent and encourages
people to act in
anti-state ways encourages people to
to violate lockdown encourages people to
protest and even be violent against
those who are taking public health
formations
you can have a deeply polarizing uh
leadership i think you've seen it in
other countries as well
so i think for instance uh in in india
we saw it to some extent and the ways
in which it was used to pursue a hindu
nationalist agenda
and to talk for instance about corona
jihadism to
to blame muslims so i think um
bad leadership in a pandemic is really
the worst of all
worlds and can divide people
but where there has been good inclusive
leadership as i say which goes along
with the measures that bring people
together
then yes i think we've seen
extraordinary levels of uh
of um of of unity and extraordinary
levels of
support so again we sometimes think of
contexts automatically changing human
behavior
no it's the way in which contexts are
understood
and made sense of it's the interaction
between the structure of experience and
leadership and the structure of rhetoric
which determines
outcomes it's not inevitable it's not
deterministic
it's the intersection of the political
and the psychological
which answers those questions well
uh that is uh all the time that we have
for today
unfortunately uh thank you to all who
are joining us from home and a huge
thank you to you
uh steven reicher for sharing your
insights with us
please visit our website at cfair.ca to
find out more about this
these series and to view a recording of
this talk which should be posted early
next week
could i make one final final point if i
may which is that the book
which we wrote we we
we wrote in order to be as uh broadly
available as possible so it is
available as a free download it doesn't
cost you anything you can buy it as a
paperback
but it's a free download so if you go to
look up together apart that's the name
of the book
um you can have it for free and you can
see some of the literature and the
evidence that lies behind some of the
things i've been saying
wonderful thanks so much steve thank you
you